session we're gonna have actually an
announcement by granola
so
[Music]
different registration is open
responsible computing.org register
there is a list of accepted because
they're already and we
um
yeah it should be a great conference
[Music]
if you don't like it
thank you for coming off for your
service that's a PC chair
um great yeah and I think it will be a
great continuation with a lot of uh
how much does it cost to register for
this country will be exactly zero
dollars okay exactly zero dollars
[Applause]
do register so we know how much
so
um thanks everyone for coming to the
afternoon session the final session for
today
um for our first talk of the session we
have Charlotte uh who is a PhD student
at Stanford who's going to be telling us
about the sample complexity of
realizable
thank you
okay thank you everyone for joining me
for my talk um and yeah as Michael said
I'm going to be talking about the sample
complexity of realizable
multi-calibration and this is highlights
from two recent works that I did with my
amazing collaborators with Yahoo and
Omar rangled are both in the audience if
you have questions
um and my plan for the talk today is
it's kind of two parts so in the first
part I'm going to talk about this
realizable multi-calibration and I'm
going to tell you what I mean by that
how we start thinking about it sample
complexity the main result and then a
little bit of the techniques and then in
the second part I want to go over
briefly some additional results we got
along the way to this main result and
this is in no way a comprehensive
overview of what we have in these papers
there are a lot of additional results
but I think at least this one I want to
highlight just as a direction of her
future work
so luckily due to all the great talks
that have gone before me in this
Workshop I don't need to do that much to
motivate multi-calibration
but I do want to say that Beyond its
original proposed use as a multi-group
fairness guarantee we've seen all these
very strong properties that it can give
us such as loss minimization this
robustness to distribution shifts and
more generally we can think of it as
this customizable notion of predictor
quality whereby choosing our subgroup
class we can kind of Define what sort of
Errors we care about and what sort of
areas we don't
and so with this in mind it becomes
interesting to really understand
um how hard it is to learn a
multi-calibrated predictor and in
particular how many samples do we need
and so
the setting that we usually think about
is one where I get samples IID from some
unknown distribution I input it to my
learning algorithm and then I want to
Output some C Alpha multi-calibrated
predictor and I'm not going to belabor
the definition of multi-calibration but
this is the type I'm using here
um
and it's calibrated with respect to this
class C which here is a binary class our
results will extend to this more General
real valued class as well
and the thing I want to highlight here
is that we can assume anything about
this distribution so this algorithm is
going to work no matter what nature
really looks like
and we have nice algorithms to learn
multi-calibrated predictors
um the original hkr algorithm tells us
we can learn in something like log of
the size of the set of subgroup samples
and of course this is ignoring all sorts
of error parameters and whatnot just for
our simplicity
and so the question we're going to care
about today
is what if I make some sort of dis like
distributional assumption so maybe I
know something about what my world
actually looks like right this
constrained set of distributions that my
data could be coming from
and then the question becomes in this
case do I still need this something in
terms of the size of C samples or can I
actually do better in certain situations
and so this is what I'm calling
realizable multi-calibration and for
those of you familiar with realizable
pack learning it should look very
similar and so my learning setup is
going to look very similar but I'm
adding this distributional assumption
here that when I see my data there
exists some hypothesis from a
constrained set of hypotheses such that
all of the labels of my data match the
predictions of this hypothesis and again
kind of as I said with respect to the C
I'm assuming that this hypothesis is
binary coming from negative 1 1 but our
results extend to the more General case
where these hypotheses are real valued
and that's just telling you the expected
label
so are there any questions about this
model that we're going to be working
with the realizable multi-calibration
so
now that we have the model we can talk
about the goal which as I noted is the
sample complexity or how many samples do
I need to learn in this setting and
ideally what I'd like is some notion of
Dimension parametized by both my
hypothesis class and my class of
subgroups and I want it to characterize
the sample complexity and so what I mean
by that is I want it to be an upper
bound so I can give you an algorithm
that needs roughly that many samples and
can output a multi-calibrated predictor
but then it's also a lower bound so for
every class or set of classes I can give
you a worst case distribution where I
actually need roughly that many samples
to learn
and in the classic you know pack
learning single hypothesis class case we
have a very nice notion that gives us
this so the C Theory or VC Dimension
um which some of you may be familiar
with but I'll quickly review
um is this notion of the maximum size of
some subset in my domain where I can
choose any possible realization of
labelings and then I can find a
hypothesis that matches those labelings
and I call that a shattered set and so
VC Dimension tells me the maximum the
size of the maximum shattered set and
you can think of this as a notion of
expressiveness so like how many
different types of Worlds can my H
really capture
and what's nice is that we know that the
sample complexities of realizable and
agnostic pack learning are both you know
VC in terms of the VC dimension of H
so already from this VC Dimension notion
we can get a natural upper bound on how
many samples we'll need to learn in this
realizable setting and it's also already
an improvement from what we had before
so I claim we can get the minimum of the
PC dimension of c and the VC dimension
of H so how do we get this well on the
one hand we have this standard
multi-calibration algorithm that can
give us a multi-calibrated predictor
with VC of C samples I said log size of
C before you can massage it using
standard arguments to get vcfc and on
the other hand because multi-calibration
or the notion that I'm using is a
relaxed version of uh standard accuracy
I can just uh straightforwardly learn h
Ive give you a good H and I've also
satisfied this task
and so this means that I can really look
at my two classes decide which one is
more simple and just learn using that
and so I immediately get this bound
which when my H is very simple means I'm
already getting an improvement over this
more agnostic setting
but the question is whether this is the
characterization that we want is this a
lower bound as well
and maybe somewhat surprisingly the
answer is no
and so I'll give you an example on when
this upper bound is not necessarily
tight
so the example I want you to think about
is I have a domain of data and I've
split it up into two halves and so right
here I have kind of two copies of the
domain on the board and I want to talk
about what's happening in my class of
hypotheses and what's happening in my C
Class
and so on the side with h
half of the domain is completely
constant any hypothesis you look at is
just going to have all once on the other
half of the domain however H is
extremely expressive let's say any
possible labeling you can think of I can
find an H that matches this
so going back to the VCA theory that we
talked about before this is going to be
a very very difficult class to learn you
know it's going to be VC Dimension
roughly the size of this right half of
the domain and so I'm going to need many
many samples to learn a good age
now on the other side I have something
similar going on for my class of
subgroups but things are flipped and so
on the side where H was very expressive
I actually have no subgroups that care
about this half so you can't find any
individuals that are part of a subgroup
whereas on the other side of the domain
where H was constant now any particular
like any arbitrary subset you can think
of I can find a subgroup that exactly
matches that sub subset
and so again this is going to have large
the C Dimension this is going to be very
difficult to learn and so using that uh
minimum of the two classes bound
I can kind of assume that this seems
like a really difficult problem
now it turns out it's not I can actually
give you a predictor that's
automatically perfectly multi-calibrated
but with um
without seeing any samples and the
reason why it's pretty straightforward I
already know exactly what one side of my
domain looks like just because I've told
you it's the same for every single
hypothesis and on the right side it
really doesn't matter what I output
because my class of subgroups doesn't
care about that side
so even though it seemed like this class
should be really hard to learn we have a
very trivial
um
a very trivial solution that took no
samples
are there any questions about this
example and how I got here
cool so really the main takeaway of this
example
um and maybe even the broader takeaway
from this talk that I think you should
really
um Come Away with I'll be happy if this
is the only thing you remember is that
characterizing the sample complexity of
realizable multi-calibration is going to
require more than just kind of looking
at these two classes independently I'm
not going to be able to find something
where I look at one and look at the
other and give you some combined value I
really need to understand how they're
interacting and then more how that
interaction is going to affect what the
sample complexity actually is
and so it turns out that the
quantity we need is a somewhat natural
extension of these C Dimension and this
is something we call the mutual BC
Dimension and so if you remember I
talked about how VC Dimension cares
about the maximum shattered sets of a
class
Mutual VC Dimension is going to look at
all the sets Shattered by my C and all
the sets shadowed by my H and then look
at the intersection so look at all the
sets that are Shattered by both classes
simultaneously
and I'm going to call the mutual VC
Dimension the size of the largest subset
in that intersection and so while we
could kind of think of VC Dimension as a
notion of expressivity you should maybe
think of mutual VC Dimension as a notion
of shared expressivity so how much the
classes can express but in the same
place
and so to really drive home what I'm
trying to Define here I'll just go over
what it would be in this example we just
saw and so if we look at all the points
shadowed by C that was one half of the
domain all the points shadowed by H was
the other half of the domain but the key
is that these halves were disjoint and
so if I really care about looking at
which points were simultaneously
shattered there weren't any and so in my
BC Dimension or my Mutual BC Dimension
would be zero and so this isn't like a
proof that this is the right notion but
hopefully this is you know maybe a vote
of confidence that we're getting closer
to uh the sort of quantity that we might
like for this setting
so it does turn out that this is what we
want and so we're able to characterize
the sample complexity of realizable
multi-calibration by this Mutual VC
Dimension and this is when H and C are
both binary hypothesis classes and I
said before we can extend to real valued
settings and in this case the notion
that we use is we take VC Dimension and
we use the analogous notion that we
usually or we often use real valued the
fat shattering dimension and we still
kind of Define it as this place where
both sets are being this shattered
simultaneously
um
are there any questions about
any of that that I went over
cool
um
and so I think just one minor
observation I want to make about this
result is something that kind of comes
from our definition of the mutual BC
Dimension which is that it's uh somewhat
symmetric so I can take H and C or C and
H and I'm getting the same value which
kind of means I could flip my subgroup
class and my hypothesis class in terms
of multi-calibration and get around the
same sample complexity and this is a
kind of property that we identified in a
few of these related learning tasks you
can see more in our papers we called it
sample complexity Duality and it's very
interesting to see where this appears
and where it doesn't and
um yeah so
I think quickly I'm going to look at a
peek at how we get this result because I
don't want to just throw it on the board
and tell you to believe me and in order
to do that I want to go back to the
multi multi-calibration algorithm that
Michael very nicely presented on Monday
and I'm not going to go into as much
detail but the key uh takeaways from
that algorithm was we start with some
arbitrary predictor p
and we input this P along with some
samples into some weak agnostic learner
for C and using this combination of
inputs we can get a good update
direction for p which can bring us
closer to a multi-calibrated predictor
and then we can do this step again with
the new p and again and again and again
until we get something that is a
multi-calibrated predictor
as we saw that we can bound the number
of iterations and so what we really care
about in terms of sample complexity is
how many samples do we need at each step
in order to get this good update
Direction
the key insight for realizable
multi-calibration is that this task is
maybe a little bit stronger than what we
need in this setting we actually know
something about the distribution we're
seeing
so it's enough to actually use a weak
agnostic learner for C with this
assumption that our Target distribution
is part of a constrained class
and with that in mind this is something
that we study more broadly and call a
comparative learning task so kind of an
agnostic learning task but with another
distributional assumption and this is
the task whose sample complexity we're
able to Bound by this Mutual VC
Dimension and through that argument we
can potentially reduce the number of
samples you're using each step and then
reduce the overall sample complexity
any questions about
yeah I'm so you can think of this as uh
we're looking for something with like a
highly correlated
like
uh a Direction that's highly correlated
with something we're doing bad on so uh
this is like my current
uh predictor whatever I'm inputting and
then this is like the true label
um
does that make sense
you're trying to learn
so could you repeat the point you you
mentioned that this is the Lee agnostic
learner is stronger than what you mean
yeah so basically um
if I take away this
I'm saying you know I need a weak
agnostic letter and I'm not assuming
anything about what the real ground
shoot distribution is and
here I actually do know something about
what my graduate distribution is
um I can assume that it looks like
something from my past transformed by my
current hypothesis and that is like a
easier a strictly easier problem than
just whatever boost over any
distribution just something that looks
like this yeah
so with the time I have left I want to
go a little more deeply into this kind
of agnostic learning task with a
distributional assumption uh
just because I think it's interesting
and worth looking at uh
and basically as I kind of hinted and
said more uh less formally in the last
slide
what comparative learning really is
doing is it's combining
uh be realizable and agnostic learning
tasks that most of you are likely
familiar with but just to go over uh
again in realizable learning we make an
assumption about our data and so we
assume that when we see labels they're
labeled According to some hypothesis
that we can find in a constrained class
but then we still require the uh error
of our hypothesis to be very very low
and here my error is just like the
number of mistakes I'm making I'm
working in a binary setting
and then kind of uh
alternatively agnostic learning doesn't
make any assumptions about my data it
says it could be anything but I'm not
going to require you to be like have
really really good error I'm only going
to require you to have error that's
competitive with the best I could do
from some constrained hypothesis class
and so the key thing to note here is
that I'm in both cases I'm using a
hypothesis class as a way to relax my
assumptions but it's being used in very
different ways and moreover it's being
used in ways that don't need to be
mutually exclusive and so comparative
learning introduces two hypothesis
classes and it says that I have one
that's kind of telling you something
about what my data may look like but
then I also have a second that's um I'm
going to call a benchmark class that I'm
using to compare what sort of error I'm
getting
there's a
um
are there questions about this
definition
um
and yeah so this is the notion we end up
calling comparative learning
so in our paper we show that this notion
is what's characterized by the mutual BC
dimension
and the proof is based on a reduction to
another learning task of learning
partial hypotheses which I'm not going
to get into here due to time but the
priv is actually quite simple so I'm
happy to talk about it offline to anyone
who's interested
and more interestingly we also explore
comparative variants of other settings
so this notion of like having something
with which we compare our error to but
also having a distributional assumption
is not something that needs to stay in
this binary hypothesis class case we
look at online learning we look at
boosting so a notion of kind of boosting
a weak comparative learner to a strong
comparative learner and then also
regression so where we might have real
valued hypotheses and are trying to
minimize some loss function
and
I think the real takeaway here is that a
this notion of comparative learning
really opens up this new setting with
tons of different learning tasks that we
could explore and try to understand
better
um but additionally what's especially
interesting is we saw that it may be
somewhat surprisingly had this
application to multi-calibration
um and so it could be used as a tool for
other problems and so really exploring
how else we might use this notion is
um to me at least a really interesting
direction of future work
um yeah and so that's all I have but I
want to put up these two papers here
especially because they look nothing
like the title of the talk
um and yeah feel free to ask questions
now or later
foreign
[Music]
for this comparative learning case we
kind of take these two classes and merge
them to look at a class that really
captures where these two classes agree
and where these two classes visited and
so in terms of that there's maybe a
symmetry between you can't really decide
whether it's better for like if there's
a disagreement
maybe it's equally weighted towards like
whether you'd prefer the thing we're
comparing against or the thing that
you're getting your data from it's like
what is truth and what's the high
purchases exactly
um so that that's maybe the my high
level I think that it's an interesting
question that would be interesting to
explore I think something else
surprising is we get this duality in the
distribution free setting where we're
not making any assumptions about the
distribution but um we can show that it
breaks down when you're making some
assumption about what your distribution
over like X is may look like and so it
doesn't
always hold
sorry can you say more about that you're
saying that if your distribution on sex
it's the universe where some known
distribution
result is that I
where you can't flip them around
these results are even like statistical
in nature if they say like how many
samples do I need to alert this class
and then do they also say anything about
the computational hardness of
implementing noise
easier
yeah I think
um
that's an interesting question I'm not
sure I'd have to uh think more about
that I think uh
certainly in terms of the example I gave
it you know you pull out this very
simple thing but it also required like
maybe a deeper understanding of what's
going on in both of these classes that
might be like kind of required in order
to pull out this simpler sample example
foreign